- Yeah, so in 2007,
I was 13 years old
and we didn't have
anything to eat anymore.
So we were thinking,
what do we do.
There were tons of people
dying from starvation
and I was fortunate
enough to live
on the border town
of North Korea,
so I was able to see the lights
coming from China's side.
So if you look at the satellite
photos of North Korea,
it is like the literally
darkest place on earth.
You don't have
electricity at nights.
So I was looking at
China and then wondering
maybe if I go over
where lights were,
I might find something to eat.
(solemn music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and this
is "The Rubin Report."
Joining me today is a
human rights activist,
author of "In Order to Live,"
a North Korean girl's
journey to freedom
and someone that I'm
honored to call a friend,
Yeonmi Park, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so
much for having me.
It's a real honor
to be on your show.
- I'm thrilled to have you.
Can I call us friends?
We've only hung out one time,
(Yeonmi laughing)
and it was just in
the last few weeks,
but I feel that we
are long-lost friends.
- Definitely, I've
been following you,
almost like stalking you for
the last three, four years.
I've been to your show with
Jordan Peterson in Chicago,
and I was in one of the
audience, so yeah (laughing).
- Nice, well, I do
consider you a friend
and I'm thrilled you're here
because your story is just
absolutely incredible.
And you've become a fighter
for so many of the things
that this show is about.
So let's just start
at the beginning.
For people that don't know you,
let's just do your biography.
Just tell me your story and
then we'll go from there.
- Right, yeah, so I was
born in the northern part
of North Korea in end of 1993.
So that was right after
Soviet Union collapsed
and North Korean regime
stopped providing ration
to the people.
So because in the socialist
system, the trading is illegal,
and if the government doesn't
give you food, what do you do?
You starve to death.
And unfortunately,
that's when I was born
when North Korea began
going to this thing
called like the worst
famine in human history
in 21st century.
I was born in North Korea.
I had a father, my
mom, and my sister
in a very ordinary household,
and I had no clue
that North Korea
was a hermit kingdom
or weird country.
We are truly isolated.
We don't even know
what isolation means.
And growing up in North
Korea, of course, it was
we didn't have a word for love,
we didn't have word for liberty,
we didn't have a word
for a lot of things.
- So you were 13 when
your family decided
to leave North
Korea, is that right?
- Yeah, escape from North Korea.
It wasn't like you are
getting a passport, yeah.
- Right, escape is
a much better word.
So can you just
tell us a little bit
about what that was like?
- Yeah, so in 2007,
I was 13 years old
and we didn't have
anything to eat anymore.
So we were thinking,
what do we do?
You know, there were tons of
people dying from starvation.
And I was fortunate
enough to live
on the border town
of North Korea,
so I was able to see the lights
coming from China's side.
So if you look at the satellite
photos of North Korea,
it is like the literally
darkest place on earth.
You don't have
electricity at nights.
So I was looking at
China and then wondering
maybe if I go over
where the lights were,
I might find something to eat.
And that was the motivation
why we risked our life
to escape from China,
I mean, North Korea.
- Yeah, and your story of
actually how you did it
is pretty incredible, so you
have to tell that to everybody.
- Yeah, where I was, we had to
cross a frozen river to China
and there are like
every 10 meters
the border guards
with the machine guns.
Now the North Korea
bury their landmines
and electrify the wire fences
to prevent people to escape.
However, when we were escaping,
we had a person, a
human trafficker.
He sold us to Chinese
human traffickers,
and that's how we were able
to safely cross the
border to China.
- Did you guys know what
was gonna happen to you?
I mean, I know you
were just a kid,
but did your parents
at that point
know you're being sold
to human traffickers,
and I know you'll tell
what happened next,
but did your parents have
any idea what that meant
or it was just like,
"We have to get there
no matter what is
about to happen to us."
- So it wasn't like my
parents deciding it.
My sister escaped a
few days before me
and I was in the hospital.
You know, in North
Korean hospitals,
your don't, of course,
have X-rays or nothing.
The doctor is like
touching my tummy
and told me, "You might have
some bursting of appendix
and we have to operate
on you this afternoon."
And they, of course, cut my
belly without any anesthesia,
and they realized that
it wasn't like appendix.
It was just malnutrition
and infection.
So I couldn't go with my sister,
but she left me a note to
say, "Go find this lady
and she will help
you to go to China."
And when I saw that
letter, I told my mom like,
"Mom, you gotta come with me."
I couldn't take my
father who was very sick.
So,
it was
I took my mom with me,
and when we were
crossing that river,
we didn't even know the
word human trafficking.
Like it wasn't something,
a concept I was aware.
The thing is, I
didn't even question
why the person was helping us.
I was so desperate and
it didn't really matter
if I was gonna get
killed in China,
my fate in North Korea
was death anyway.
So, it didn't really
matter what it was.
- Yeah, do you think your mom
knew what was about to happen
when you got there to China?
- No clue, she also had...
So in North Korea, we have
like one channel on TV
which is all propaganda
and we don't have internet.
And there is only, we
have one newspaper.
We do not have any outside
information coming in.
I never even seen
the map of the world.
I had no clue the
different races existed.
I did not even know
what Africa was.
In North Korea,
the regime told me
that I was came of some race.
They didn't tell me
that I was Asian.
So I didn't really know
how many countries existed
or none of the outside
of North Korea.
So she, of course, did not know,
we just went there and
found out what it was.
- Yeah, okay, so
you get to China,
and I think you probably
thought you were gonna be safe,
but that's not exactly how
that worked out either.
- Yeah, so I was 13 and
crossing this frozen river
with mom and the human
trafficker helping
us to go there.
And as soon as the first
thing I was seeing was
my mom raped in front of me.
And I was 13 and in North Korea
we don't have any sex education.
So I didn't even
know what that was,
didn't even know that was rape.
It was just horrible
and I couldn't believe
what was happening.
And then they told us later,
they were like negotiating
our price in front of us.
They talk about a slave
market, it's exactly like that.
They sold my mom for around
$65 in 21st century right now.
And I was above $200.
They bought me because I was
a virgin and I was young.
And they sold us separately to
different human traffickers.
- Right, and then what?
I feel like this whole interview
I could just say to you,
and then what, and then what,
because it's such
a series of things,
but I think it's
important for people
to really understand
all these steps.
- So as soon as they were
separating mom and me,
you know, even though I was
like 13, a minor, didn't care.
They were like they want to
make more money out of us
in splitting us.
They sold me to another
human trafficker.
He was like Han Chinese
and he of course
tried to rape me,
and I was trying to kill myself.
I couldn't take it anymore so
I was trying to kill myself,
and he said if I
become his mistress
and he would become buying my
mom and bring my family to me.
I was in a way very lucky
that I found the trafficker
who wanted to help me that way.
So at first, I
thought like, okay,
if I become his mistress,
I can save my family.
And I did become his mistress.
He raped me and did
bring my mom back.
He bought my mom from
the farmer he sold to.
So because due to one-child
policy in China right now,
there are more than 30
million men cannot find wives.
North Korean women are
demanded by these men
and sold as sexual
slaves to them.
- Did you think your life
was better at that point?
Like did you feel better now
suddenly you had
seen a wider world,
but horrific things
were happening to you?
I mean, the rape of your
mom, the rape of you.
It's not that you were free.
Like what did you
think at the time
in terms of like were things
better, was it worth going?
- I stopped feeling things.
I think through my therapy,
that's like my struggle right
now, trying to feel again.
Like at 13, somehow I
just learned not to feel.
So it wasn't like I was
thinking about, am I happy here?
It wasn't like that.
It was like, every
second was survival
and trying to not get
caught by Chinese authority,
because they were like looking
for us like every second.
- Yeah, all right.
So, let's get to,
I mean, your whole
book is about this,
so let's jump instead of
doing the whole story,
to now where you
start becoming free
that kind of leads you to now.
- So from China,
we learned later
that if we go to South
Korea, we can be free.
And how do we go to South Korea?
We don't have
passports, none of that.
So we learned that if we
walk across the Gobi Desert
to Mongolia from China,
then Mongolia might help
us to go to South Korea.
So that's exactly what we did
right after basing
on MPD in 2009.
we did grew up nursing,
the factors and myself
we brought a one
compass in our hands
and in February it was freezing
like minus 40 degrees
in the desert.
We followed the
Northern star to freedom
and that Rocky take
us to Mongolia.
And then eventually a
few months later they
did help us to go
to South Korea.
And that's how I
became free at 15.
- Yeah, I mean, it's
hard to believe.
So how many people were you with
when you were crossing the Gobi?
- We're like seven, eight,
and we had one baby,
like two three years
old to ride with us.
- And you had a compass
and the North star
how long did it
take you to cross?
- It took us
several days journey
to go to in the
Mongolia in china,
and then from the night,
it was just one day.
But we chose the
coldest time in February
because during the summer
time is so literally watched
they can just shoot us.
But you know, in
February, normally think
like somebody should to be
crazy enough to cross desert
in like minus 40 degrees.
- Yeah, did you think that
you weren't gonna survive?
I mean, were there
moments where.
- Yeah, I was, I like, I
remember still remember
standing on the desert, like
I felt completely
alone in this world.
We normally would have known
if I stay on the desert. Right.
And that's what I felt
like so many people dying
without like,
even more knowing about
it completely invisible.
And I just thought like
what scared me most was
not even dying that night.
It was just like,
no one gonna knew that
I existed in this world.
- Well, they definitely
know you exist now.
So you, when you got to Mongolia
what did you have to
give people to trade
so that they would help you
get to South Korea from there?
What's in it for
them at that point?
- Yeah, so Mongolia has
some kind of theory with
South Korea.
And as soon as we got
caught by Mongolian soldier
and they were like using
guns trying to shoot us.
And the thing first
thing was doing to them.
Like I was thanking them
because I could have been
just easily lost in the desert
and no one could have found
us, at least soldier, found us.
And they were of course,
trying to send us back
to China and then
some back North Korea.
But when North (indistinct)
when they escape, they are like
during the Holocaust
Jews brought us like
poisons with them.
That's what we do.
We bring lasers and
poisons with us.
And if we called them back
we were gonna just
kill ourselves
before we go through
all of that journey.
And they were trying
send us back to China.
And then we were trying
to take the poisons
and to kill all ourselves.
And they took a pity
on us and they actually
contacted South Korea instead
of the North Korean one.
And they have dust to go
to South Korea as refugee.
- All right.
Well, since I know
from hanging out
with you for a couple of
years, a couple of hours
I should say, I know what
a nice smile you have.
So let's get,
to the part where this starts
turning into a happy story.
- Yeah
- So now you end up in South
Korea and what happens?
- I'm learning how
freedom is so hard.
It was very difficult to be free
because in North Korea, like
everything was decided for me.
Government's telling me what
to wear, what to listen to,
what to watch and so in
South Korea, they say like
what do you think?
And I was only wondering why
does it matter what I think
just tell me what to do.
And they said, what do
you wanna be? It's like,
so the fact that in South Korea
I had to be responsible
for my choices
which is so hard to
adapt in the beginning
coming from North Korea.
And I was thinking like
if someone guaranteed
my life safety,
I will do this go back North
Korea and be slave again.
That's how hard transitioning
was coming from, you know
North Korea to free world.
- How do you make that switch.
its mentally
- Books really helped me.
I was starting reading Georgia
West animal farm in 1984.
But to that point, you know
when I was arriving
in South Korea,
people were telling me
like Kings or dictators
and you were lied, you know
everything you learned
in North Korea was lie
Americans are not pastors.
And you know, they're
like Japanese are not.
And they're like
they keep telling me the
good things about the world.
And by that point, I was like
completely lost my
faith in humanity.
I was thinking, so like
if everything that I believe
in North Korea was a lie.
How do I know what you
are saying is not lying
- Yeah
- Was really hard
to believe again.
- How do you get over that.
I mean, that must be,
I'm guessing the scars
of that have to be with
you right now still.
- No, Georgia while
reading his book was just
made complete sense.
Like I could see in that
little pigs in the animal farm
was it, I see myself as in
my grandmother's like, Oh
this is what happened.
And so I became really good
friends with the books.
And of course I've been
so inspired in your book
don't burn this world.
And
- That was years later.
You were already on your way
by the time you read my book.
So then what did you start doing
in South Korea that started
getting you some notoriety
and people started
knowing who you were
and then in 2014 and it
seems like that's where
things really started to catch
on at an international level.
- So in South Korea never
planned to be an activist
or none of that,
but I lost my sister,
as I said, I lost her.
She escaped me when she was 16.
And then I was 13 and we
I didn't see her
for like, from 2007.
So I realized in order to
find that I need to get
on like the news sort of
broadcast to find her somehow.
So I started joining a TV shows
in South Korea and
looking for her.
And that like really led
me to activism later.
And yeah, but I found my sister
though, seven years later.
So it paid off.
- Yeah, what was that like?
I mean, it sounds like
such a ridiculous question.
What was that like? But.
- I mean, she is the only
living family that I got
from all of this.
Like, because of my spoke
out against the dictator
all my three generations of
my family back in North Korea
being sent to prison camp
or being executed
because I'm speaking out.
So I'm not still free
from the dictator.
There are still consequences
for me having a voice
and she was alive.
She was the only one that
I got from all of this.
- Yeah.
And then how were
you sort of welcomed
into the Western
world after this?
I mean, now you live in
Chicago now your friends.
We have a ton of similar friends
that are all fighting
these battles,
but you've lived
through this battle.
How did, you go from
just sort of activism
in South Korea to
where you are now?
- Yeah, in South Korea,
unfortunately I was,
heavily discriminated
and I couldn't fit in.
I had to lie to people
that I was South Korean
'cause they were not so many
things like South Koreans
who were discriminated
against for North Koreans.
And that's why I chose
to come to America.
Even the people who say
this is like racist country.
This is a country I have been
where most embracing included
in my life.
So I chose U.S as my
home cause it's like,
there's no racism for
me here to experience.
- Right before we
get to the non-racism
of the United States.
So, South Koreans
were discriminating
against North Koreans.
Was that, simply
because they didn't know
North Koreans or they
felt that too many
North Koreans were coming
over or what is that?
'cause you don't really think
that there would be that
type of discrimination
- Just because we are
coming from a poor country
and you know, South
Koreans, they discriminate
against like Southeast Asians,
like Vietnamese, Thailand,
Filipinos and North Korea
is also poor country.
I don't think they
discriminate people as much
when they come from
France or Europe,
Western Europe, or like USA,
but do that when people
coming from poor country.
So, even though we were
saying people, when I went
to South Korea, they were
just making fun of my accent
'cause I was speaking with
Northern accent and, you know
they were asking me
like, are you a spy
why are you talking to me?
And it's like, if I were
spy, why would I even escape?
So it was very tough.
- Right.
So what put you on my
radar was a few months ago
a whole bunch of people
started sending me a video
of you talking about
your adventure and your
journey and everything else.
And you happen to
mention that you read
"don't burn this book"
and that it helped you
in some way, which is
I don't even have the words
to explain my
gratitude for that.
I mean,
it's just beyond imagination
considering what
you've lived through.
But in essence, you are now
here in the United States.
Do you consider yourself
an activist first?
Like what do you consider
yourself now? Really.
You're an author obviously.
And you're out there
fighting all these battles
but what do you
consider yourself now.
- I'm a fighter,
and am trying to fight against
North Korean dictatorship
and Chinese communist party
that sponsors dictatorship
in North Korea.
And I think that's why I began.
I mean, on chair, I read
your book and it was
I was more trying to
be, you know, what
like try to do my best
to raise awareness.
And at Hollywood, everybody
they don't pick up
North Korean story.
Like they talk about slavery
and they talk about like
Malala, who was shot by Taliban.
They talk about what
was captured by ISIS,
and Michelle Obama with
standing up alcohol anchors
or these people in the
mainstream standing up
for a lot of girls and like
human trafficking issues.
But nobody here in
like West wants to talk
about North Korea
because that offsets
Chinese regime.
- Is it?
Yeah, Is that crazy for you?
Like you come here and you see
this sort of fear
around talking, not
just about North Korea
but we talked about
this a little bit
a couple of weeks ago.
just that you see the way
we are afraid of
speaking up here
in the freest
country in the world
about whatever it might be.
- Yeah, I mean, that's like,
that's so shocking to me.
And I thought America
was like land of the free
the home of the brave way.
That's like how I thought
of this country to be
and coming here and like,
the movies when they make
about North Korea to
exposing the dictatorship
the Hollywood, like
drop the sponsorship.
And there's no way I
can like talk about it
because there's Kim
Jong-un can never exist
without Chinese comments
part of the sponsorship.
There's no way he can
be dictated right now.
And he's imprisoning
25 millions of people
and the United nations,
they are saying
only resemblance we can
see what's happening
to North Korean
people is a Holocaust.
That's what, Holocaust it
happening again in North Korea
and the world denying again.
And the mainstream, of
course, Hollywood and media
deny me because they don't
wanna like upset China.
- Yeah, I mean, is
it that obvious?
Like, it's that they just
Hollywood just wants
Chinese dollars.
Their last transformers
movie, you know
they really wanted
to push to China.
So they film part of it there
and they put all the products
and all that kind of stuff.
I mean, is it
really that simple?
It just comes down to money
and they see a new market
there and that's it.
- So that's like
what I only recall.
I discovered last few
years that I've been,
keep trying to talk to people.
And then as soon as I talk
about the (indistinct) China
as being human trafficking,
all of that, they were like, Oh
I cannot put my name on that.
And so yeah, in those days it
was like, Oh, I cannot, like
I care about what you
do, but like, I can never
like support you on this.
And they have no
problem supporting like
a lot of other causes.
And also though I work,
I mean, my movie has been
trying to make, and other
movies were being made already.
And this major production
companies gave money.
And then as soon as they
were like appreciated
by like these other
platforms, they just drop the
sponsorship and they say
like, I cannot show this movie
- So when you see like,
you know, there was
the big controversy
six or seven months ago
with the NBA players that
would in criticize China.
And yet they'll
tell you how racist
and everything else America is.
It must just blow your mind.
- I mean, but even
though it blew my mind
I couldn't speak out
because I was scared.
You know.
Like they are gonna,
what, how am I gonna, like
I need to fight for my people.
What if all these country
gonna make me a CIA spy
and blah, blah, blah.
You know, being a
racist, all of that.
Like how do I even get a
chance to fight for my people.
Maybe I still need to be
like somehow being
acceptable to them.
But like, I knew
I was robbed in
Chicago this year,
during the summer on rest.
And I was punched by
these two black women.
And then, I was trying
to ask them like
can you, like, I was
asking people help.
And she was punching me
and taking my wallet away.
And these people were
standing, calling me a racist
like this like middle of the
Chicago, Michigan Avenue.
I still have a
footage of the scars.
And they said you are a
racist, you're a bad person.
While are you doing
this, like color of skin
doesn't make them thieves.
I was like, I mean, I
have nanny who was Muslim
and he jumped, like, I'm
a (indistinct) person.
Like why would I do that?
And of course those
girls were theives
the police got the fridge
of them using my credit card
spending $3,000
(indistinct) or something.
- [Dave] Yeah, we already know.
- And I just couldn't
believe it like
the people were seeing me
this, I was very petty.
As you saw me, this big
three black women were
like pushing me the
corner and punching me.
And then they still calling
me a racist and like
they're holding me down
so they can run away
so I cannot call
the police on them.
And that's like, Oh my gosh
I cannot believe that I
have a son in this country.
Like, this is not a
safe country anymore.
Like, things are not
like, okay anymore.
- So what do you make
about what's happening
in the United States?
Cause one of the
things we were talking
about a couple of weeks
ago is that the chill
around free speech that just
people are, you said to me
I think this is
exactly what you said
but correct me if I'm wrong.
I mean, you said this
is right now feeling
like what it felt like.
I know this feeling from
- Well, before I say always
I get like first thing my mom
taught me was not even whisper
because the (indistinct)
hear me in North Korea.
And now I'm same thing like
trying to teaching my son.
Like when you cross
the, like, what grade?
And do you know, like crosswalk,
there's like white man
like walking sign
and he's like, we are
so of course he was
like light color and man
and he says, white
man, I can walk.
And people are
looking at him as like
you cannot say you're, I cannot
I'm like always teaching him
to be, how not to be attacked.
And like, this is
exactly my mom did to me.
Like I just like, and what also
what I see in America is that
when I was going North Korea
I was like third generation
of this oppression.
I didn't even know what
the alternative was like
but my grandmother knew
she was living under
the Japanese colonization
before Kim she lived her life
and before at that time who
knew what was different
existed, they stopped.
And they kept the silence.
And by the time
when he came to us
we didn't even know that
we were slaves to Decatur.
And that's what they say
like why there's no
revolution in North Korea.
And I was like
how do you fight when you
don't know your slave?
- So when yeah.
So when you see that now,
the way we're afraid
of speaking up
and the mob is gonna get
you in council culture
and we have these lock
downs and we, you know
don't spend time together
on thanksgiving and all
of these things does that
strike you as just the perfect
storm of all of these bad ideas
that could lead us to
something like North Korea.
I mean, I know it sounds
crazy at some level,
and yet here we are.
- So the thing is
that, I used to think
that macros is winning and
like, you know, those older
like communist socialist
countries were falling apart
but it's not any
more look at China.
We would use new
advanced technology
and North Korea they said
they are getting
this A.I recognition
why they can't even
afford food to people.
They are bringing all these
machines from China too.
So then as people,
and that's like what I'm
seeing that, you know
we cannot take freedom
for granted because it's
a very fragile thing that
we got and look at China
like Chinese system's
not going anywhere.
And that's what I'm
scared in America is the
oldest technology censorship,
and it's mainstream.
And you have to somehow
conform to their idea
and otherwise you get destroyed.
And I think America is in that.
I don't know.
I'm so scared for sure.
- Yeah, Yeah
what do you think America
should do related to China?
Like what would be a
sensible policy then?
I know you're not a policymaker
specifically, but like
what would be a sensible
thing we could do
in relations with China?
- So it is, I mean, I was
just talking about it.
It's a miracle start.
I think that's what
Trump enlisted.
Like he was, even though
he messed up (indistinct)
at least like he made a point
about how China is responsible
for so much problems
in this world.
And you know, the problem
in here right now, like if I
as soon as I talk about
how China sponsors North
Korean dictatorship
and how they are enslaving
human beings right now
not like few centuries ago, like
there are slaves right now,
slavery happened in China
but like that just
does get buried.
And I think that's,
what's important.
Like American government
should inform people
what's happening and
how the species you know
committing crimes
against humanity.
- Yeah, when you
hear people talk
about Donald Trump and
they'll come, you know
compare him to Kim Jong-un,
they compare him to the
to these worst
dictators of all time.
And here you are in America,
we're in a particularly weird
time at the moment, you know
potentially in between
administrations
or maybe not nobody even knows,
but we just had elections.
And obviously
we'll find out how
legitimate they were
and all of that stuff.
But when you hear those
direct comparisons,
when they're made about Trump,
what does that make you think?
- Complete ignorance.
It just unbelievable
ignorance of the people
who actually dare to compare
Trump to Kim Jong-un.
There's no comparison
on this earth.
There's no absolute comparison.
Almost makes that's the thing
I used to talk about like
media was so busy making fun
of Kim Jong-un and his haircut
and how we did groceries
for her and making them is,
I mean, something so funny
you lose a gravity of
seriousness of the issue
and it's like, they are so
easily comparing to anybody
to Kim Jong-un or Hitler's
like there's no comparison.
God is like in line that
you should never cross
because then we don't
realize how evil it is.
I mean, maybe also
it shows a sign
that they never have ever
seen like true evilness
to be able to compare
Trump to that.
- Yeah, and so what
about the Democrats?
I mean, you know,
now there's a feeling
that Biden is gonna be much
closer to China or something.
I'm guessing you're
not thrilled with that.
- Yeah, Obviously.
And I mean, it's like,
it's so horrible.
It's so maddening
that even I have to like
talk about North Korea
but I need to choose
a political side.
Talking about the real effects
how China is committing
crime against humanity.
And then as soon as I talk
about like how we need
to challenge China,
and talk about freedom
of speech in this country
then it's like, Oh,
you're like ultra vibing.
Like how talking
about those basic common
sense makes me ultra
like extreme was a premises.
So that is like so unthinkable.
And I'm here to
fight for my people,
but now I'm also gonna
I had to fight for my
freedom of speech in America.
- Yeah, what do you make
of the sense where like
just where we're at in America
and forgetting the election
just generally, like, you know
you mentioned some of
the negative things
that have happened to you
but obviously something
truly incredible things
have happened to you
at the same time.
- So, yeah.
I've been also starting
my YouTube channel
and like I was going live
and talk about
how pure socialism
can be so poisonous
can never work.
And of course, I'm
sure you know that,
like YouTube (indistinct)
videos. Right.
And I was wondering
like, how like
any ideas should
be offered debate.
I thought that's
what freedom meant.
And here we have this
like, called of like
where we have to.
I mean, I went to
Columbia in New York.
You can, how it felt
like for me going
through another four years
of oppression, they're like
they talk about
oppressional remember
there's another oppression
that they cannot see.
And I think that's why I
just don't know like how
even to fight
I feel like I came to America
like four or five years ago.
And like, well, you guys
always like this crazy.
Like how this
- We weren't, I promise you,
we weren't always this crazy
but we need people like you
to help us find the way again.
I mean, that's why
I wanted to have you
on the show because you've
lived through this stuff.
You've lived through it.
And then when I saw the video
and you're somehow
referencing my book
and I'm going, this is crazy.
I mean, you lived through it.
I'm talking about this
stuff at the idea level.
Although I fear that most of
the things that I was worried
about in the book are
starting to become true.
- Yeah, It's, I mean,
until I got robbed
and seeing people how
they're like, you know
this is something you did read
like on the like conspiracy
theory, like news sites.
These people were standing
on the Michigan Avenue
in Chicago, like 2:00 PM,
like during the
day near the Macy
and police cars
are there nearby.
And these people are
seeing me being punched
and calling me a racist
because they only see,
the only thing they could see
was a color in their eyes.
The other group, I was
like, Asian, that's all.
And that's when I thought
like, Oh, this is like, not
it's not like I'm
trying to own people.
This is a complete gone madness.
And I don't even know
how to go back to the
like the middle zone where
some sanity like whores.
- Yeah, you sort of referenced
this a little while ago
but the idea that
if you talk about these
things, freedom, free speech
all of the things that
you've just described here.
But if you talk about them,
you're suddenly thought
of as like right wing that
this is now a right wing thing.
How has that affected your
ability to do your advocacy
and build bridges
and things like that?
- That's the thing it's so hard.
Like how they are just so easy
to call him names now. Right.
They're so busy, like
making few new names
for people and then putting
them into this little box.
And it's been very challenged,
like actually do even these
like all my friends who
are like, you are fighting
for American people,
you can not doing this.
You cannot talk about
any of these problems.
Just stick with North Korea.
But like in order to North
Korea and solve those
I need to like
solve China first.
The problem with North Korea
the root is Chinese regime.
Like communist party,
is not Kim Jong-un.
Kim Jong-um can never
serve even one day
without (indistinct).
So I'm how do I like fight with
massive fight without
like letting people know
what's happening and what
China is doing to the humanity.
And then as soon as I,
of course, criticize
mainstream media for not
like highlighting this issue
then you know, I'm
becoming a white, extreme,
like crazy person.
- Yeah what do you think
about our media here?
So as someone that grew
up with, as you said
one channel,
our media, our mainstream
media kind of feels
like one channel
at a certain level.
- I mean, it is the one
channel it's, I just, I can't
I mean, I like listen to like
NPR, BBC, and you're kind of
like all one story.
Like, why did they even have
different, like, publications
if they're going to have one
narrative, they should just
make it one channel, like
North Korea so much easier
for people to follow.
And I think it just, it
just reminds me of like
the animal farm,
how it all began.
And the beginning, just
like, don't thinking, Oh
it's not a big deal.
It doesn't affect
my life right now.
And then suddenly, like, you
start keeping being perched
and being executed.
And we are not in this state
where like, we are executed
but like, you literally
get cancer and you don't
like news platform, social
media, like you lose your voice.
And that is almost like similar
execution for like activists
like me.
Like, if I lose my
people, like my influence
then I cannot let them
know the truth. Right.
How do I ever find the system?
And like, my like, fight is
depending on the tech companies
they make decision on me,
like one day, like, Oh
I can let her be heard
and I can be heard.
But if they decide I cannot
be heard, I cannot be heard.
It's not up to me anymore.
And that's like, what
does fixing my within.
Like, how am I despite.
- Yeah, you know it's
interesting when people
ask me what I love most
about doing the show,
it's this right now
because think about like,
our lives are so different
came from such different places.
And the things
that you care about
are the exact things
that I care about.
Like, it's actually
incredible how these
sort of eternal ideas just
end up bringing us together.
- Yeah, it does.
I mean, I think if freedom
is something that we can
I think that's what I'm
so like, scared for going
to Columbia is like,
they don't understand
like people when you're
born with like two arms
you never know what it feels
like living without two arms.
And these people like at
Columbia keep, like wondering
about what would they be
like without like freedom.
Like they have no clue what
it's gonna be without it.
And they keep trying to
experiment this new idea.
And there's like, no, I
mean, I know what it feels
like living without this,
like whites and freedom
and why are trying
to keep abandon them.
Our ancestors fought for
our freedom of speech
and then they blow
their brother for it
freedoms is not for those,
there was a price they pay for,
and now because they die for
free, they just don't wanna
see what it feels
like without two arms.
And it's not that great.
Like it's, your life is
going to be so miserable.
And I think that's like, what?
Chuck's demean horrifies
me how ignorant
And this evil is like
ignorant Idea he is.
- Can you also talk a little bit
about how it's not just like
the bad actors that
spread these ideas
but how the average person
just kinda gives up.
Like what you saw in North
Korea when you were a kid.
And then China, when you
were a little bit older
about how the average person
just sort of checks out.
Cause that seems to be the stage
that we're in right now here.
- So yeah, I was thinking
like, so in North Korea
if you commit a crime,
it doesn't end with you.
Like it tracks two, three
generations of your family,
sometimes eight
generation, which means
like your in-laws or
cousins, cousins like that.
So one night the factory
skater who was high lever
he's like, I mean, 30,000
people got purged for that.
And like, usually it's
three generations.
So your grandpa, your
children, all of it.
And like in America
now, if it's like
if I say something that
was maybe completely aware
30 years ago, it
gets back to me.
And I don't know, what's
gonna get back to me 30 years
down the road and how
it's gonna affect my son.
Like people talking about
something that happened
in the like time
in ancestral age.
And they have to be
responsible for that.
But it's slavery
thing that is like
exactly reminds me of that Like,
because some, my
ancestors did so many
many lifetime ago, how
does that affect me?
How does it make me
figure it. Right.
And is a complaint I
get from North Korea.
I don't know where these
ideas are coming from.
Like we're making people
so guilty and shame them.
And that's one of those screws
all about shaming people
and make them feel
guilty and punish them.
- I mean, just the fact that
you see those parallels here
and I can just hear
the way you say it.
You know.
- I mean, it's easier now
because we have internet
they record everything.
In North Korea if I were looking
of not letting anyone to
be heard, I'll be fine.
But here, like as long
as something's recording
you can never escape from it.
And that's why they
get redemption is
like impossible in
this culture now.
And again, North Korea,
like local to play the role.
But here, I don't even
know like how visual this
like the system of
trying to punish people
and trying to catch
people who is like
not opening their ideology.
- Do you think there were people
in the North Korean system
or even in the Chinese
system today that just
selected out, that
just disappeared from
any sort of public
life whatsoever
or just their families
just disconnected
from the world in a certain
way, 'cause I do sense
that we're gonna start having
a movement towards that,
that the whole system will
be so out of control here
people will be so afraid to
say anything that I think a lot
of celebrities are
just gonna disappear.
I think a lot of people
with the means to do it
are just gonna disappear.
But I also think just
regular people will figure
out ways to just not
have anything to do
with anything that's public.
- Well, I mean, that's,
and it's American.
We have that room for
doing that. Right.
But in North Korea,
you can't like
if you literally get executed
if you read the newspaper
that has a Kim's face on it
that's how insane it gets later.
Like North Korea, I think almost
like the perfect example
where we gonna end up with
if we are going this route
of like keep poaching
people want to make them like,
think the one way, right.
Like there was no
diversity of thoughts.
They don't allow that.
Like, they talk about diversity
but it's not about diversity
of ideas and North Korea
We are always pushing that.
But no diversity of thoughts
like one idea always
hold the truth.
And in China, at least
there's some distance
but you never meet.
We never hear, about
this is in North Korea
'cause they get to zero
tolerance for any descent.
It's just purging right there.
We do like all
their family members
and they are gonna be punished.
- All right.
So since your story
ultimately is a good story
but obviously we're talking
about some scary stuff here.
Tell me a little bit
about your work now
the way you affecting people now
and some of the hopeful
parts of this stuff.
- Yeah, there's some of
the hopeful stuff. Okay.
So
I
that's something I have
been trying to more
like tackling the symptoms
of the dictatorship
which I was trying to work
with the NGOs in South
Korea to rescue the factors
like myself, when I,
if you are $2,000.
You can rescue one
nursing defector
from oppression to freedom.
That's what I have been doing.
And also I've been
trying to get information
inside North Korea, as I said,
there's no other information
and trying to get noticed
and people understand
that they are slaves,
that they are oppressed.
But the thing later I
realized I cannot be just
keep rescue people.
This is not gonna ever
change in North Korea.
In order to change and
bring down the dictatorship
I need to get China to convince
and they stop the sponsorship
of this dictatorship.
So that's why I began
studying my YouTube channel
and trying, because like no
newspaper pick up my story.
As soon as I talk about
China, they don't pick it up.
They drop the line
and I can never talk
about how crucial it is
to solve North Korea.
Whenever people say like,
how can I help North Korea?
And there are many
ways, but the main ways
of raising awareness about
Chinese regimes role in this.
So they stop be patilation
of North Korean defectors.
So North Korean defectors
are not like other Syria.
Other webpages.
They have a country
tried to accept them
which is South Korea.
South Korea had their
constitution say that
anyone was born in Korean
(indistinct) their citizen.
So when we escaped from
North Korea to South Korea
we become Citizens
automatically,
all China has to do, to
help North Koreans is that
they don't catch us.
We are not even asking
China to establish
and staying there as refugees.
They just have to
let us go through
to South Korea to Mongolia.
It's not that hard.
It doesn't cost them anything
but they don't wanna do that
because they don't want
the regime to collapse.
And they, this is what I
really wanna highlight. Like.
We need to somehow
make the campaigns
that China doesn't do this most
primary repatriation policy
against Northern people.
And they stop this human
trafficking right now.
Like if you go to Baidu
and Chinese Google
tons of information about how
to find those screen guide,
like, it cost me $900
why not to buy a car.
And why we're busy
talking about slavery
that happened
hundreds of years ago,
it's happening right now.
And how can we allow
this as a humanity.
It's like Holocaust
happening again.
- Yeah, I mean, there are
literally concentration camps
in China, active
concentration camp. Right
- To like, I mean the
whole country knows Korea
is like prison camp,
entire country's border was
there to the wire, like tenses.
And then the mines,
how it's not that is that
they're not okay. Right.
You cannot go to
North Korea right now
and do journalism,
right my prelim camp.
And nobody's like
talking about this.
- All right.
Yeonmi for people
that wanna follow you,
that wanna help you,
because I think you're
gonna get a nice burst
of people right now.
Where can they follow you?
What's your YouTube channel?
Like let's blow up beyond
me park brand right now.
Come on.
- Thank you, my YouTube
channel is called
the voice of North
Korea by Yeonmi Park
And they can find me on
Twitter, Instagram, Facebook
not on Tik TOK though.
- Not on Tik TOK.
All right.
Very good.
Well, we're obviously
we're gonna put all
the links down there
and I know you're
in Chicago now and I'm
here in Los Angeles.
We're in oddly
authoritarian places
but I hope that we
can meet up soon.
And it's just great
to see you again
- So great to see you.
Thank you for having me again.
- Yeah, thank you.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
instead of nonstop yelling
checkout our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.